The joe rogan experience.
Oh,
I screen capture all that time all day.
There really should be sexual service industry.
There really should be,
you know,
the idea that that's illegal.
It's so fucking gross.
You know,
I think it probably causes more rape causes more anger if prostitution.
Yeah.
I don't want my daughter to be a prostitute of course.
But if prostitution was legal,
so people are going to do it and guess what?
Some people are going to actually like to do it and some people get to enjoy
going there and some people,
they're just crazy bitches and they really wouldn't do anything else anyway.
Right.
And what are you gonna do?
Are Going gonna fix the whole world.
You're going to fix the whole world or are you gonna let them get tested and get
taxed and let them be treated like they're not some outlaw,
you know,
it's not an,
it's,
it's an outlaw thing.
If you're a prostitute,
Europe criminal,
if you're giving away sex for free,
you're just a whore.
But if you're actually getting money for it,
you go to jail,
they lock you in a cage.
And the idea that we still have that in 2011 regardless of what your beliefs are
about sex,
whether you should or shouldn't go to a prostitute.
I agree that it's kind of a weird thing.
It's a little dehumanizing.
The whole conditions.
It's very strange,
but fucking for sure it should be legal.
You just can't lock people in a jail.
You lock people in a cage for making someone feel good with their mouth.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
It's insanity.
It's absolute fucking in Santa.
Can Lunacy man complete in Santa Ana and the fact that it's not challenged,
the fact that that's not challenged in 2011 like,
and the fact that Apple's not censoring it off as Siri,
when you're asking for a blow job and they tell you what they look,
the closest escort agency is.
Did you know that this is what he did?
He asked it.
He was asking,
Oh,
I haven't told you this last night.
I just sit there in bed and try new things,
you know,
and I'm sitting there,
he'll go,
I need,
I want a blow job.
And they're like,
we found Ford escort agencies closest to you and it was like 27 miles away.
You know,
Steve Jobs is program some shit in there.
That's it.
Just waiting for someone to say the right thing.
I just hope they don't start censoring it though.
Apples keep on going that way.
Make it like the Internet.
Don't start censoring it.
That's fucking cool that you actually have that in their portal.
Siri.
He just put it in there knowing eventually.
Right.
Okay.
What is exactly going to happen on December 21st,
cannot access future node.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That's fucking cool man.
But one thing that seems interesting,
it seems like that it's a run off a server because it's been,
you know,
everyone's activating the Siri,
which is a remote assistant on the new iPhone four s is what we're talking
about.
Well you know what it's based on,
right?
Uh,
the dragon or no,
based on Wolfram Alpha,
which was that search engine,
it was created by all these PhDs they wanted,
they literally wanted to put together the concept is a website that can answer
any question.
So no matter what your question is,
you know where I'm going.
What is the weight of one pound of nuclear waste it before I've used it for
shipping.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
so apparently that's what,
that's what,
what's behind all that?
That's really cool.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
When you ask for a dead body,
it a sewer,
an old warehouse.
A junkyard,
where to put a dead body.
Yeah.
You didn't make that.
I thought this is a fake.
No,
no,
no.
I've been laying in bed and using it just like fucking making up shit.
Holy Shit device.
If you ever have a gadget and want to learn everything about it.
I just bought Brian One too,
right?
Then I say,
where are we at now?
And he's like,
dude,
this is what I just found out and he'll find shit on it that you would never
figure it out yourself.
Fucking know.
Yeah.
Well he's just a gadget whore.
I need to figure it out.
Take you with them and I think it's run off a server like I think like that
they're going to be able to constantly upgrade it as time goes on.
And I'm just worried now that with all the attention to all the,
of course the x rated stuff that they're going to start censoring.
It went and I hope they don't start doing that and,
but,
but it is cool to think like what Siri in five years is going to be,
just like when we first saw the iPhone one to see how it's changed the
technology from then it's going to be pretty much a PR,
like most relationships without sex,
it's going to be better than that.
You know,
it's,
it's going to be anything you want to talk about,
any questions you have to ask and you're going,
it's going to learn,
it's going to get to know you.
It's,
you know,
it's pretty much going to be like artificial intelligence.
I think that is those relationships,
that sex because what else is that?
You're sitting there talking to a computer.
Most of them.
Oh,
like most like a relationship without sex.
You know,
know what,
you won't feel the same.
That's what the,
if you know that the robot is there for you because it's artificial,
you're going to abuse it.
It's not like a person that you love to have around.
I think most people would probably just beat the fuck out of the robots.
Right.
I knew that the robot wasn't a person but was always going to like look out for
them and be there for them and then you would find that role but ignoring and
you would kick his ass cause you know he couldn't fight back cause it's a bit of
a protective right.
But if it gets to know you better and me,
I'm already late.
Oh man,
it's a robot.
But if it gets to know what your answers would be in your personality better
cause I'm already interested in it and it's just not even smart right now.
But what if it starts to get to know you and now you're so interested in it,
like crack you want to asking what if you fall in love with your phone?
Yeah,
she's,
she has things,
I even asked it to sing the other day and it starts singing me a song.
I mean,
it's pretty much,
it's,
it has,
it's fascinating.
Like I wanted to,
I'm addicted to it.
I'm addicted to,
Brian just got a cursed iPhone.
It's not Siri.
It's got a demon in it.
Okay.